During the Purge, all crime is legal, so this
isn’t even a question right? You should definitely
be able to steal stuff. The answer isn’t that
simple. If you Purge someone during The Purge,
the whole act is concluded before The Purge ends.
But The Purge Season 2 shows us that if you’re
still on private property after the conclusion of
the last siren, they can book you for trespassing.
So what if you steal something? Are you required
to drop it before the end of the final siren? Is
it considered possession of stolen property the
moment the 12 hours of the Purge have elapsed?
If you’re watching this on the day of
upload, Happy Purge to each and every
one of you. My initial plan for today’s
festivities was to upload my Things You
Missed episode on The Purge TV series --
however that’s gonna take a little bit longer,
but I couldn’t leave you with no
Purge video on Purge night, so....
Before you head out there and do your own
purging, it’s best to know and understand
the rules, and I’ve been seeing this
question a lot in my comments lately.
If you steal something during The Purge, do
you get to keep it? The answer is… sometimes.
[INTRO]
To answer this question, let's look back at
things that have been stolen during The Purge.
In the original movie, Mrs. Sandin hangs the
Polite Stranger’s rifle after he is purged,
but Dante Bishop gives back the gun that he
acquired from The Sandins, though this could
just be because the family had already lost
so much and he wasn’t gonna take anything else.
In Anarchy, Leo, Cali and Eva steal weapons
and a vehicle from the woman who hosted
the Purge gala. Leo leaves the girls in the
car while he goes to take care of business,
but he’s critically injured just before
The Purge ends. Before the sirens sound,
Eva and Cali get out of the car to go aid him,
but they hang onto the guns. It’s safe to say
at this point that stolen guns can be kept, but
when they’re trying to get Leo to the hospital,
they don’t seem to consider using
the stolen car they were just in.
EVA: “You got a car?”
WARREN: “Uh.”
EVA: “You got a f***ing car?”
WARREN: “Yes.”
EVA: “GO GET IT NOW!”
So they use this guy’s car to get
Leo to the hospital. It seems like
cars cannot be kept if stolen during The Purge.
We don’t see anything else get stolen during
Anarchy, but we can learn more from this line.
LIZ: “It’s so quiet here.”
LEO: “Business district’s
always quiet on Purge night, the banks move
their money, so no one’s ever down here.”
The fact that the banks move their money suggests
that there is an incentive for someone to try to
rob the bank, which does happen in a
later installment. We’ll get to that.
Next is Election Year. The main story ends
just after midnight, so we never actually
see the end of that Purge, however there
is an item that is attempted to be stolen.
“I want my candy bar. And I’m gonna take it!”
Yeahhh… Kimmy tries to steal a candy bar.
I think we can all agree it’s no surprise
that this would be allowed, especially
if you eat it before Purge ends. Marcos
comes back after the conclusion and finds the
whole deli ransacked, so it seems likely that
any food items are fair game to keep after
The Purge, regardless of if they are eaten.
Another note to make about Election
Year -- it takes place in the future,
and Dante is still easily able to hotwire a car,
which he only uses for a moment before his death.
But my takeaway from this, is that
it’s not difficult to steal a car,
so the fact that The Purge hasn’t become
a free-for-all for every parked car on the
street must mean that you can’t
keep a vehicle if you steal one.
The fourth movie is the prequel, The First
Purge. This time we actually get to see a
couple robberies take place. One man
attempts to pry open an ATM machine.
If you’re not allowed to keep the money you
steal during the Purge, he has no reason to
be out there risking his life. We also see a
group of thieves target a cash for gold store.
“I’m exercising my right to Purge by taking all
your merch, and if you stand in my way I will f***
you up! Let’s f***ing Purge y’all!"
This place has jewelry, guns, gold and
silver. They’re stealing more valuable items,
which tells me that what can and cannot be kept
probably isn’t so much related to the price tag.
So far it seems like cars cannot be kept
post-purge, but any items small enough to
hold in your hand are fair game, including money.
What about larger sums of money or larger objects?
While The Purge Season 1 does
not have much thieving going on,
Season 2 introduces us to a band of bank robbers.
What happens is interesting. Three of them make
it out of the bank before Purge ends, and
they get to keep their money. But Tommy
gets caught with his foot on the line as time
expires, and they book him for armed robbery.
However, they later find out that they amount they
stole wasn’t actually that much, because the banks
are keeping most of their money in an airplane
throughout the entire duration of The Purge,
so next Purge they come up with a plan to prevent
the plane from taking off, and take in a haul
upwards of 100 million dollars, proving that
the value of products stolen is not a factor.
The money is kept in these huge rolling cases
which they unload from an armored truck onto
their boat. This has me convinced that the size
of an item isn’t necessarily relevant here either.
Their plan was always to stop the plane
from taking off. They never seem to
consider hijacking the plane. Maybe there are
practical reasons that they couldn’t do that,
but the fact stands that the idea of trying to
stow away in one of these cases and take control
of the plane is never even brought up. Which leads
me to believe that planes are also off limits.
But there is perhaps an even more important
detail I noticed in Season 2 that answers
another previously unknown question. What
about houses? Can you take over someone's
home or business, purge the inhabitants
and claim it as your own property?
Season 2's story revolves around the death
of a character named Drew Adams. Her friend
Esme stops by her house after she
is gone and encounters two realtors.
“I’m so sorry. We’re just doing a first
inspection. Did you want to look around?”
“Or are you thinking of buying? The owner was
just purged and we think it’s gonna go very fast.”
It would appear that if a person
is purged, their home can’t be
claimed -- instead it just goes on the
market. This is kind of a dark detail,
the NFFA can just purge people and
turn a huge profit on their house.
So you can't keep real estate or vehicles.
If you steal a car, have fun on your joyride,
but you better be out of it by 7:00AM.
Same goes for real estate. But you can
keep other items or money, no matter
how big, no matter how valuable.
So what is the logic behind these
rules? I think I have the answer.
All crime is legal during the Purge. You cannot
go back and try to arrest someone after The Purge
for a crime that was committed during The Purge. However,
if that crime is still happening when The Purge
concludes, it’s considered an off-Purge crime.
That’s why Tommy is arrested for still being at
the bank. If I steal $5 from you, it’s my money
now, as long as I steal it during The Purge.
Money, weapons, jewelry, food and other common
items are transferred by hand to hand exchange.
For example, if you give someone
a cookie, it’s assumed that you’re
giving them ownership. Even if it’s agreed
that they’re just borrowing the cookie,
it’s ultimately going to be on
them to return it. You voluntarily
gave the cookie to them -- so no crime was
committed even if they don’t give it back.
However, that’s not how you transfer vehicles or
real estate. If I wanted to transfer ownership of
my car to you, which I don’t, what do I look
like David Dobrik? -- I’d have to fill out a
title certificate, sign it, and go to the local
DMV to officially transfer the ownership. The DMV
is not open during the Purge, so transferring
ownership is impossible. Meaning when I wake
up on March 22nd the car still belongs to me
no matter what happened in the last 12 hours.
Even if the car title is stolen,
the DMV has a duplicate, which they can
still give a copy of to the legal owner.
“For, eh, a small fee.”
There is a similar process for transferring
real-estate. Once again, you have a title as proof
of your legal ownership. You need to have to get
a real-estate attorney who will prepare the deed,
the legal document that transfers ownership
of the property. You’ll need to sign
the deed in front of a notary, a public
officer who is not available on Purge night.
These processes also apply to aircrafts, boats,
trailers, businesses and probably
submarines. I mean, I didn’t look it up,
but I’m guessing submarines. So the Purge
isn’t useful for stealing these kinds of items.
You may be wondering, OK, what if I just use
The Purge to steal a car, hide it in a garage,
then sell it off the record for cash or for parts?
Sure, you’d be committing a crime, but because
there are no emergency services during The Purge,
there’s a good chance you’d get away with it.
Well, that’s not so easy either.
The Purge takes place in the future,
and we already have modern vehicles that
are practically impossible to steal with
two factor authentication. However, based on how
easily Dante hacks the car in Election Year,
let’s just assume the criminals have
evolved as fast as auto security.
Even then, you’re not gonna get very far.
Dante drove the car all of 20 feet before
getting purged. With GPS tracking, stolen
cars are becoming a thing of the past.
Even if you’re an experienced
hacker and managed to disable this,
good luck relocating the car when
nearly every street in America is
covered by cameras and watched over
by a team of NFFA surveillance agents.
So your best bet is going after that cold
hard cash. Or a candy bar. Man’s gotta
eat. If you have other questions
about The Purge, drop a comment,
and maybe I’ll answer in a future video. Check
out my purge playlist on the left and remember
to subscribe to CZsWorld for new horrors every
week, ring the deathbell for ALL notifications,
and I’ll see you in the next purge. Assuming we
both survive. If you don’t want to get purged,
stay home. If you have to go out for essentials, wear
a mask.